Willkommen zur Einführung des Kurses Technische
Modezeichnung mit Adobe Illustrator.
Die technische Modezeichnung, was ist das?
Modeillustration, Modezeichnung, technische Zeichnung,
vielleicht habt ihr diese Begriffe ja schon einmal gehört.
Ich möchte euch die Unterschiede zeigen.
Der Hauptunterschied zwischen einer Modeillustration und
einer technischen Modezeichnung liegt im Zweck.
Die technische Modezeichnung dient zur Kommunikation mit der
Produktionsfirma.
Sie ist Teil von den Produktionsunterlagen und sie zeigt,
wie das Kleidungsstück hergestellt werden soll.
Eine technische Modezeichnung wird flach dargestellt.
Im Englischen wird sie auch als Flat Drawing bezeichnet,
also flache Zeichnung.
Es ist also so, als ob ihr euer Kleidungsstück ganz flach
auf den Boden legt und dann auch ganz genauso zeichnet.
Die technische Modezeichnung ist exakt,
das heißt von der Proportion sollte sie wirklich auch die
Realität widerspiegeln und wir zeichnen in der technischen
Modezeichnung alle Details ein,
also alle Nähte, alle Schließsysteme, Knöpfe,
Reißverschlüsse, Versteppungen, alles,
was zu diesem Kleidungsstück gehört und was wichtig für die
Fertigung ist.
Eine technische Modezeichnung wird
so neutral wie möglich dargestellt und bildet sowohl die
Vorderansicht als auch die Rückansicht ab.
Meistens ist das dann in schwarz-weiß und oftmals auch mit
einem Zoom auf bestimmte Details, wichtig sind.
Wir nutzen dafür auch eine ganz neutrale Perspektive und
vermeiden hier auch jeglichen Hüftschwung oder jegliche
Stilisierung, die die Zeichnung in irgendeiner Weise
abstrahieren könnte.
Im Gegensatz dazu dient eine Modeillustration
der künstlerischen Darstellung oder auch der
Inspiration und dazu bedienen wir uns allerlei
künstlerischer Mittel- und Darstellungstechniken.
Wir können also diese Modeillustration auf ganz verschiedene
Arten und Weißen darstellen, zum Beispiel mit Aquarelle,
mit Tusche, aber natürlich auch digital.
Die technische Modezeichnung kann man auch per Hand
malen,
aber es ist natürlich auch ein sehr langer Prozess jetzt
wirklich ganz präzise alles per Hand darzustellen.
Deswegen benutzen wir digitale Programme zur Unterstützung,
wie zum Beispiel Adobe Illustrator.
Und der Vorteil von diesem Programm ist natürlich,
dass wenn ich einmal technische Zeichnung angelegt habe,
kann ich sie auch immer wieder verwenden und dann verändern,
sodass ich dann am Ende auch viel schneller technische
Zeichnung erstellen kann.
Also noch mal zusammengefasst,
eine technische Modezeichnung ist keine Modeillustration,
denn sie hat einen ganz anderen Zweck.
Man benutzt sie,
um Kleidungsstücke herzustellen und zu kommunizieren,
wie diese hergestellt werden.
Technische Modezeichnung sind flach, neutral,
man stellt Vorder und Rückansicht dar, sie sind
maßstabsgetreu,
symmetrisch und zeigen alle Details wie Nähte, Abnäher,
Taschen, Verschlüsse etc.
Sie sind rein funktional und sachlich und sie werden häufig
mit Adobe Illustrator erstellt.